- The only brownies I ever
ate growing up were these.
It's the recipe my mom would
make to bring to PTA meetings.
We had it for dessert at dinner parties,
it's like, these brownies
are always a hit.
Hi, I'm Alexis deBoschnek
and today, I'm gonna show you how to make
my One-Bowl Fudgy Brownie recipe
for my upcoming cookbook,
"To the Last Bite".
There's walnuts, there's salt,
it's fudgy, sweet, savory,
it's really my perfect brownie.
First, I like to line the
pan with parchment paper,
just so it's easy to bring
them out of the tray.
Place the chocolate in
a microwave safe bowl
and microwave it in 30-second intervals,
just until the chocolate's melted.
Now that the chocolate's melted,
you're gonna add the melted butter
and use a hand mixer to
beat until just combined.
(lighthearted guitar music)
Now, add the sugar, combine again.
Alternatively, you can
do this in a stand mixer
or even by hand.
Add vanilla extract, then eggs.
(lighthearted guitar music)
And once again, beat until combined.
Add kosher salt, and flour,
and just carefully combine,
making sure not to over beat the batter.
These are really fudgy brownies.
They've got an incredible texture.
I had some walnuts for a bit of crunch
and some flaky sea salt on top
so you're really balancing
that sweet, savory flavor profile.
But if you don't like
walnuts or have an allergy,
you can use another type of nut.
Pour the brownie batter into the pan
and then use a spatula to smooth the top.
(lighthearted guitar music)
Pop them in the oven, and they're
gonna bake for 25 minutes.
(lighthearted guitar music)
I like to top my brownies
with some flaky sea salt,
but it's really important
that you let them cool
for at least 30 minutes.
You just lift them out of the pan,
(lighthearted guitar music)
slice away, and enjoy.
One of the reasons I love these brownies
is that it's all done in one bowl.
Easy to make, easy cleanup,
what could be better than that?
This is just one recipe
in my upcoming cookbook,
"To the Last Bite".
It comes out April 19th and
there's over a hundred recipes,
many of which were
inspired by my childhood,
like these brownies.
(lighthearted guitar music)
Mmm.
They're fudgy, they're sweet,
they're salty, the perfect texture.
I really hope you make these brownies.
(lighthearted guitar music)
- [Tasty] Oh, yes!